different specialization tracks that
includes oncology infectious diseases
Precision medicine Neuroscience data
science or biomedical data and
comprehensive training on omic's data
analysis
students will also have access to omex
logic resources but how does it help
Advance bioinformatics teaching omic's
logic is important for practical and
theoretical learning of bioinformatics
it takes a combination of training
modules data analysis tools curated
project data sets and interactive
sessions with mentors to give the
student a clear path up the Bloom's
taxonomy pyramid and no matter what the
user's initial experience with
bandformatics is omic's logic is a
useful tool for gaining a baseline
knowledge of the theory behind
bioinformatics analysis of large data
sets and introduction to basic coding
languages like R and python or even
beginning a data analysis project
this also comes with an access to the
omixology courses which includes courses
on bioinformatics Precision medicine
multi-omics including genomics
epigenomics transcriptomics as well as
metagenomics and data science that
includes bioinformatics using RN python
as well as chem informatics and example
projects of different fields which you
could learn from and replicate for your
research work users will also be given
directions to access the T by info
platform for bioinformatic processing
and Analysis of data the platform
includes demo pipelines as well as data
management and Analysis Cloud
infrastructure to run biomismatic
pipelines and different stages of
analysis are performed in different
sections on this multinomics platform
so to view the various courses example
projects and student projects you need
to first sign up on the omistological
encoder but before that let me walk you
through a brief demo on what a completed
profile on the portal looks like
so once you sign up on the portal these
are the features that you need to update
on your account that is a completed
profile will have a profile image full
name with appropriate capitalization
link to your social media handles that
includes Facebook LinkedIn Instagram
work ID or even Twitter a brief bio
about yourself that will consist of your
educational background and research
interest and the mentors can view your
progress under the activity Tab and the
courses you are currently completing
will appear under the courses tab
finally after the completion of your
course the certificates will appear
under the certificates tab so now you
might be wondering what comes after
completing the courses and example
projects the answer is and for the
answers possibilities are endless for
instance you could go on to perform a
research project like gazelle a
bioinformatic graduate from Amity
University Rajasthan who completed a
research project in the field of
oncology she uploaded a project on the
learn portal where an International
Community of students peers and
bioinformatic experts can watch her
presentation recording read through her
research project like share and comment
their feedback under the comment section
in the chat box I am pasting the link to
her project
so that the participants can take a look
and another interesting student project
outcome can be seen in case of the Lara
Daikin a molecular biology and genetics
graduate from the University of turkey
who completed a project in the field of
astrobiology which she went on to
present at the psyomix club session a
session where an International Learning
Community of biomedic enthusiasts come
together to share their work debate on
important topics and share their queries
to stay up to date with latest
advancements in the field you can take a
look at her session recording in this
link and pasting it in the chat box
and in addition she also went on to
publish her project as a pre-print on
bioarchive that she can share with her
peers mentors and potential employers
for future connections and the link to
the publication has been pasted in the
chat box
further you also have the opportunity to
participate in post-representation
competitions as a part of the omics
research Symposium like Dr Umar yadav
who worked on a machine learning project
for which she won best technical
research project as well as exciting
cash prizes and this Symposium is an
international research Symposium that
brings together experts such as Dr
Gareth trouble and Dr Joseph Borg and
among so many other experts who join as
guest speakers and judges and here's a
link to her testimonial video where she
talks about her project as well as
winning the price
the students are not just limited to
graduates and doctorates for instance
Andre murdeno Sosa a high school student
at Mexico presented his Neuroscience
project at the regeneron international
science and engineering pair for which
he won potamkin prize and the fourth
award in the biomedical and Health
Sciences category and here is the link
to the blog where you can read more
about his book
all right so now to view the various
courses and example projects student
project let us Begin by signing up on
the omics logic learn portal
so for those of you who are signing up
for the first time here is the link for
signing up
please click on the link and I'll walk
you through the process behind signing
up on the title
so once you click on the link this is
what you'll be able to see so to create
an account you can simply click on this
and then it will ask you to enter your
name email ID and your password and you
also have the option to create an
account using any of your existing
social media accounts that includes
Google Facebook Apple account GitHub
account or even Twitter
and with that I would like to pause for
a couple of minutes so that the
participants who have not signed up can
sign up on the portal and once you have
completed a uh your account on the
portal please leave a yes in the chat
box so that I know I can proceed further
and if you already have an account on
the portal please leave it done in the
chat box so that uh I can get a rough
estimate of who I'll have already signed
up
and with that I will pause for a couple
of minutes
okay so we have a lot of people who have
already signed up
and if you're facing any technical
issues you can leave them in the chat
box as well all right thank you so much
we have most of the participants have
signed up
so uh since I also have an account
number option I'm just going to click on
the login now option here and sign in
using my existing social media account
and once you sign in uh you'll be able
to view the various courses and example
projects so suppose let's say you have a
specific field of Interest so that you
can just enter the keyword that you're
interested in so let's say you're
interested in machine learning so please
you can just simply enter the keyword
machine learning
and you'll be able to see the various
courses and example projects that makes
use of this concept and now coming to
the part where I was talking about
updating your profile for that click on
the tab that says welcome back put your
email ID and it is important to update
your profile since the community manager
and the mentors of the program will be
tracking your learning progress so how
do we update your profile so that we
have to just click on this button that
says profile and here update your
profile image a brief description about
yourself that will consist of your
educational background and research
interest and it is also important to
keep your name with appropriate
capitalization and you also have to link
your social media handles as well in my
case I've updated my LinkedIn account
and my work ID now this is where this is
the part where the community manager and
the mentors of the program will be able
to track your learning progress under
the activity Tab and as explained
previously the various courses that you
start taking will appear under the
course staff and once you upload a
project like gazal bhargava it will be
displayed under the projects Tab and
once you enroll for any of the programs
such as the research fellowship program
this will be displayed under the program
staff and once you've complete any of
the courses with appropriate assignment
and business if the certificates will
appear under the certificates that now
you can also browse through and navigate
the various student projects that you
are interested to look at
this uh this consists of a wide range of
topics from oncology infectious diseases
Agriculture astrobiology and so on so
you can navigate through at your own
pace and take a look at it so here also
you can just enter the keyword that
you're interested to browse through so
let's say oncology and that will display
the various courses that makes use of
the uh topic so without further Ado now
I would like to pass on the stage
she is our research fellow and she has
completed a masters in biotechnology
from Amity University and has joined the
research fellowship program once again
to publish her research project in
peer-reviewed journals so without
further Ado over to you
thank you
uh yes
no that's fine
um yeah just share my screen
thank you so much
so I blew my screen is visible yes thank
you
hi everyone my name is
I completed my BSC and MSC in
biotechnology from Emmett University
Noida
and I I joined uh
find bioteca research hello in December
last year and I've completed a project
and I rejoined to complete my uh process
for publication
so
my dissertation was I did it from
Manipur University it was based uh
on wet lab
it was finding out
how a particular Gene in Gila cell line
would
uh add to the progression of cancer so
it was wet lab but then I had interest
in dry lab as well and I wanted to learn
more about it
that doing oncology so I joined by find
biotech as a research fellow
was my guy
and he's still guiding me for the
process of publication
uh so initially we were made to complete
some courses uh which SRI gory has shown
us uh those were python molecules Pine
for in Python bio ammo an introduction
to bioinformatics these are all basics
courses that needs to be completed in
order to in order for us to move ahead
so uh you can do bioinfo in r or bio ML
and R that's upon you whichever
programming language you're interested
in
and after learning this as I wanted to
do in oncology I had to decide which
type of comics I want to go for either
genomics or transcriptomics proteomics
or any other
and I chose transcriptomics because I
wanted to work on RNA transcripts and
gene expression
so I completed a transcriptomics course
which gave us
a proper and clear idea about how RNA
transcripts can be used to analyze
then a process in a way that we would be
able to find out how genes are expressed
differentially in different types of
conditions in different conditions and
based on that I started my
independent uh project
so my independent project was uh based
is based on relapse in AML which is
acute myeloid leukemia in two treatment
conditions as you can see in the image
we have the allogenic HTTP which is
hematopoietic cell transplantation and
another one we have the Intensive
chemotherapy so these two treatment
conditions are
are being uh used uh rigorously in AML
as of now and they are quite effective
as well but uh the problem is uh relapse
of AML is inevitable
so I wanted to study how these two
treatment conditions and their relapses
has differences in the level of gene
expression that is the first purpose of
the study that I wanted to find out and
I
I also wanted to find out how in
transplantation uh the AML would affect
affects the neurological processes
because I found that uh many
neurological disorders were implicated
so I wanted to study further and for
that uh the transcriptomics courses
helped me
and
right now I'm working on
making a paper fit for publication so
I've completed a project but and the
analysis and everything but I am
preparing uh the paper because I need to
change writing and the images so that it
is fit for publication I'm also
searching for uh publication platforms
such as
journals through the platform such as El
Xavier web of science with nature to see
what kind of journal and which impact
factor would fit my uh quality of an
area of the paper
oh I'm also working on making the
supplementary section and the images and
Devils that need to be inside the paper
and I wanted to go for
open uh close access publication because
for open access I'd have to pay
something and that that would be huge so
I wanted to go for close access
and my in end goal is to apply for
higher studies because I want to go for
a PhD in the area of oncology
I wanted to implement both wet lab that
I did in my dissertation and dry lab
that I learned from here
to build up a research proposal so that
I can apply for my higher study
that's my journey thank you
thank you so much
and as research fellows who might be
interested to join like I have few
queries for you that is even when I was
starting out with the research
fellowship program I had this doubt of
how can I narrow down and focus on uh
specific uh data set type of data set
such as should I choose the
transcriptomic should I choose genomics
so you were able to narrow it down to
transfer term so could you please share
how you were able to do that and how one
can go through a similar process
um
it looks like yes you're right yes
um I I chose transcriptomics because I
wanted to study uh the MRNA transcripts
uh
of how the genetic expression uh would
affect like I wanted to study more into
the biological really biological
Pathways so I felt that uh studying the
gene Expressions would help me
understand how
the biological Pathways would are
affected
by cancer so
that's why I choose transcriptomics
right and also like uh you have chosen
the feeler specialization as oncology
right and in oncology itself there are
lots of cancers that you could work on
like breast cancer lung cancer and so
much and your field of interest is AML
so how did you come into that conclusion
that you want to work with uh in the
topic of AML
um I believe at that time there were a
lot of research papers that were uh
were written and uh talked about in AML
and how the relapse are still an issue
so I thought I would work on AML
and try to understand the relapse
in these
right and uh during the part of your
coursework and example projects were
there any example projects that you
really liked and if so like why did you
like it
um example project so I went to PDX
I believe
uh because it was related to cancer so I
I
do that project
right and then uh how did you find the
mentor for this program and how do you
come to know about this program in
general um I I came to know about it uh
through Linkedin and I was assigned Dr
raghavendra and he is prominent in
cancer studies in
bioinformatics I believe uh and others
as well but I was assigned Doctor around
so
and he's like a great mentor
right and there is also often a stigma
that when you're completing a research
paper it's mostly if you want to
transition into an academic field do you
think that completing a research paper
will be helpful in if you want to go in
an industry related field
yeah Industrial Research or so on uh
yeah I I believe that
I believe that would help us work
because in
industry you uh people do data analysis
as well so
uh that this will help them or guide
them in a way on where to start off
and how do you plan on using your
existing research uh you plan on getting
the research project published right
yeah yeah and so after publishing how
how do you think it will help your
career like which track are you uh
planning to opt do you uh want to work
in Academia or you want to go into
Industrial Research
how is it
um I want to go into Academia and I want
to pursue my PhD and I believe this
would add to my CV for application and
the area that I want so I believe while
writing for my research proposal
and also uh
relation to my area of interest is
in cancer so I believe this would help
me out
and the second last uh query that I have
for you is along the way that you are
completing the program did you were
there any mistakes that you made and
that stuck with you throughout the
program experience that that you would
like to share it with other research
fellows when they are enrolling for the
program
um stuck as in
for example in my case when I enrolled
for the program I didn't uh I feel like
I didn't go through the coursework uh as
much seriously but then when I started
taking up the example projects I felt
that the theoretical background was very
important because uh a lot of the
theoretical Concepts that are covered in
the coursework is what that will be used
in the example projects in an applied
way so that was one of the learning
mistake that I had so similarly do you
have any such tips or advice for the
students who are just enrolled yeah I do
um so like uh my like I opted for Bio ML
inviton and papaya info
in I applying as well right so I kind of
skimmed through the examples and uh the
answers but like I felt like I should
have tried to run it on my own more
thoroughly and try to understand it more
so that I could work with python more
efficiently
uh that was one of the
uh one of my problems
that I faced
thank you so much and finally would you
like to recommend this program to
everyone
yeah I would I'm still on it and I would
recommend to anyone who would want to
start out with uh or mixed data analysis
uh whichever career path they want to
take take but um who wanted to intrude
or mix into their uh studies I would
recommend for those people
thank you so much nivedita now before
moving on to the next part of the
webinar we will have a short poll and I
would like to request uh sparsh to build
up the poll so that it will be an
interactive session to make it more
often track yes so the questions will be
displayed in front of your screen so
um just answer your interest wise like
the questions that are being displayed
on in front of your screen
so I'll just read them out very quick
that is how important are bioinformatic
analysis tools skills and resources in
your current field of work is it
extremely important is it very important
somewhat important not so important not
at all important
and the second is do you find that an
online learning community is helpful in
keeping you motivated during your
learning experience
and that would be significantly helpful
very helpful somewhat helpful or not at
all helpful
and the third question is are you
interested in completing a research
project and getting it published in a
peer-reviewed journal yes or no
and what topics are you interested to
work on for your research project that
is genomics transcriptomics metagenomics
epigenomics
and final question how did you know
about today's webinar was it your
advertisement organic social email
marketing or through reference
so I can say that 23 10 people 11 people
out of 34 have participated it would be
great if you could fill it out as well
rest of the people
so that based on which sonalika can also
start recommending the courses for you
that will be useful to you in
enrolling for the program
a few seconds
I will wait for few more seconds uh
participants it will be great if you
could fill it out quickly
[Music]
all right then over to you sonalika
thank you so much
just a second
yes so today I would like to share some
of the resources that a research fellow
gets the access to how you can leverage
these resources throughout your training
and research period in the research
fellowship program and also we'll
discuss about some of the research
Fellowship drugs that or I'll call them
specialization tracks where you can work
on as a part of the program
has already mentioned about the omics
logic non-portal I'll quickly go through
some of the resources on the portal so
many times people get confused about
Amex logic and the server so the omics
logic is the training portal where you
have various resources put together
various courses on multi-omics and data
science and you can go through through
these resources to build an
understanding of Concepts and also learn
how to run various pipelines or do the
Hands-On practice on the T bioinfo
server in t bioinfo server is the
Hands-On practical server where you're
going to run various pipelines on
different omics data analysis so I'll
just quickly showcase you how you can
navigate VIA the courses and then apply
the knowledge that you gained from the
almost logic nerd portal to run these
pipelines on the table and for server so
when you click up under the courses tab
you have a list of courses that you can
go through now how do you figure out
which specific course you have to go
through and why I'm talking about a
coursework here
also mentioned when a research fellow
joins the program it's very important
for you to actually build the concepts
and know what you have to work on and
what should be the pipelines that you
should be running and what is the basis
behind them before you actually start
working on your research project before
you actually start applying those
Concepts to those pipelines so as a
research fellow when you join the
program you go through an intensive
training process in the first month or
in the two months if you join the six
months program so the first month is for
your coursework where you have to go
through a specific specialized training
and for that training you need to pick
some courses from the portal itself so
in the search bar if you simply type
if you select the courses tag from here
on the right side all of the courses
will be listed out to get started those
who come from a non-bioinformatics
background you can go through the first
coursework that is Introduction to
bioinformatics this specific coursework
will help you understand what the failed
bioinformatics is all about it's a very
basic short coursework and you will be
able to complete this in just a day or
few hours maybe so going through this
coursework will help you understand what
is the role of bioinformatics in
healthcare what is Big Data and
bioinformatics what is translational
bioinformatics what are the opportunity
what are the various opportunities that
you can leverage in this field and the
next coursework that you can go through
just to figure out which specific field
would you like to work with is bytes and
molecules we understand that as a
student if you are a bachelor student or
a master's student you might not have
specific research interest
or I'll call a specific research uh
topic that you that you would like to
work on and you also might not know what
other various
um omics data types in your academics
you are mostly introduced to fees like
genomics proteomics or structural
biology but what about transcriptomics
and or metagenomics or maybe epigenomics
so this is the coursework bytes and
molecules that we have put together for
you to get introduced to different omics
data Knights and also about some
research specialization tracks where you
can apply these different types of omics
data analysis now once a research fellow
completes the these introductory courses
you will be then able to pick a
specialized coursework maybe after
having a research interest for example
if you are a research fellow and you
complete these two courses after
completing these two you might get and
trust in one of these omics data types
that you would like to learn about more
so you then take up the specialized
course
now I would like to
this video all right so now let's say
from bytes and molecules coursework uh a
research fellow gets interested in the
transcriptomic specialized training we
recommend them to take up the
specialized training so the training
process is divided in three parts the
first part is the introductory phase
where you go through these introductory
courses to figure out which specific
specialization track would you like to
pick or which specific type of data
analysis would you like to learn and in
this coursework how are these courses
now arranged that is what I would like
to show you here you have some Concepts
explained about a specific type of data
analysis and you also have the
guidelines to run pipelines on the D by
info server you have a mix of coursework
put together here some content some
videos and quizzes and assignments to
also uh check the concepts that you gain
throughout the coursework are they
correct or not and now let's quickly
jump on to the T bioinfo server about
which I have been mentioning for a while
now that you have some guidelines put
together here which mentions how you can
run the Practical Hands-On using
transcriptomic data analysis on the T
bioinfo server why am I using
transcriptomic word here is because yes
I have opened the transcriptomics
coursework so we have the steps or the
guidelines mentioned here in the
coursework that you have to follow
now what is the T bioinfo server all
about
so let's quickly jump onto the T by info
server this is the Hands-On practical
server now on the TeamViewer info server
you can see various sections put
together
today in the research Fellowship webinar
I wanted to Showcase you these different
sections of the day by info server and
also let you know how easy it is to
analyze big data and visualize it
through interactive visualization
techniques or methodologies and also let
you know how you you can learn it easily
via omics logic learn portal resources
thank you just people sharing the link
in the chat box so on This Server you
will find different areas of analysis
put together transcriptomics genomics
then you also have metagenomic section
machine learning and data Sciences over
here you have phytogenetic analysis and
single analysis I would like to quickly
give you a demo on
um one of the concepts that is called
differential expression
now it's not important that most of the
keywords that I'm using here you might
be familiar to it as a graduate or or a
master student as well but uh along
throughout the training duration you
will be introduced to these keywords so
you need not worry about them all right
so now let's look at one of these demo
pipelines just to understand how easy it
is to run these pipelines that I have
been talking about and also visualize
some of the results
now what are the pipelines now these
pipelines are basically some sets of
algorithms or tools that have been put
together and a pipeline follows a path
that is you have to select a you you
start off and then you select certain
number of tools and you set some
parameters and then you end that
specific pipeline that you get that is
what is called a very in very simple
terms a pipeline I have
um made you understand this in a very
Layman language now this is a demo
pipeline in a demo pipeline you already
have the data uploaded at the backend
and this demo pipeline has been put
together for you just to see how easy it
is to run these pi to run the pipeline
with these different tools so this this
is a differential expression pipeline
where you just want to look at some
differential expressed genes or genes
that have an abnormal expression level
and then see what is the role of these
genes in different Pathways that lead to
a specific disease or a disorder so
let's quickly run this demo pipeline now
when you talk about the Hands-On part on
the table info server I just mentioned
that you have to upload a specific type
of data in this demo pipeline it's
already uploaded but when you run your
own pipeline it becomes very important
for you to first of all understand what
is this data that we have that we are
talking about what is the format of this
data from where you extract this data
and then how do you prepare these input
data files to run a pipeline after that
how do you actually run the pipeline and
set the parameters while opting or
choosing these different tools that we
have put together here so all of these
steps are mentioned again where it's in
the coursework that you have to go
through and understand first of all so
I'll select some tools here uh I
selected uh start then desircode
differential expression and for pathway
annotation I'll select enrichment
analysis in GSE and I'll simply end this
pipeline
now when I end this pipeline I can see
some visualizations that we have a look
at and also I have some results to
download
and also view now these include some txt
files and also some uh plots and crafts
that would help us interpret our results
so here is the process that you just saw
that I also mentioned from taking the
data from various public repositories to
actually interpreting some biological
insights out of this data and throughout
this research fellowship program it's
important first of all for you to
understand all of these Concepts the
flow of the pipeline the algorithms
involved the parameters to be set and
then see how to interpret these
different results once your training
process is complete then you will be
proposing a research question that you
would like to work on and start off with
your research question
let the files download and let them open
now let's quickly see what do these
visualizations look like so this is a
heat map I'll just close this that this
is a heat map where you can see which
all specific samples uh were involved in
these different or we can call say it
like this that which all are the
different types of genes which have
abnormal expression in these different
samples
all right and
I won't be going into much depth of
these visualizations right now but I
just want to I just wanted to show you
how interactive and easy it is to look
at these plots now this is a volcano
plot which shows you which are the genes
with abnormal expression level you have
these genes listed here you can see them
when you hover over the points and then
you have a dashboard where you have the
heat map here with the gene expression
value also you have these genes and
genes in respective samples in their
expression and if the expression is
abnormal and then you have the volcano
plot and then you can also pick a
specific Gene and look at the level of
expression of a specific Gene in
different samples
so this is how you can interact with
your results and interpret the
biological insights and if you talk
about Pathways meaning if you click on
the enrichment tab here then you can see
which all genes that you just saw
artificial expressed they are involved
in which Pathways and again you have the
gene ratio here
and the expression as well
so that is how easy it is to actually
work with data
now when you join the research
fellowship program we understood that
you have to go through a specific
training uh or let's say a specific
coursework in a specific type of omits
data analysis it could be
transcriptomics it could be genomics it
could be metagenomics or epigenomics or
structural biology now we you are well
versed with a specific type of data
analysis and you have to then pick a
research question the question arises
here which specialization tracks can you
work on which are the different research
areas or research fields that you can
work on so to help you with that we have
put together a page that lists various
research project topics that you can
pick from we can share this page with
you I briefly go to page in the webinar
today won't be going into much depth uh
right now as uh we are short of time so
the link is in the chat box you can go
through it go through each one of these
questions that you can pick to work on
in the research fellowship program
now we basically work in six different
specialization tracks
the first one is infectious diseases now
on this page what we have done is we
have listed the specialization track and
then we also have the different types of
omics data analysis that is possible for
each of these specialization tracks and
under each one of them we have the
research questions uh present that you
can answer or that you can pick for your
research question all right so the first
is the infectious diseases track that
you can work on and then we have the
different types of data analysis uh
possible present over here you can take
your time and read through each one of
these questions that you would like to
answer
and then we have the second
specialization track that is oncology
and again different uh types of data
analysis types possible Precision
medicine is the other type of
specialization track that we are working
on then we have Agriculture and and then
we have neurosciences metabolic
disorders and space comics
so you can go through this the research
project topics over here that you would
like to answer as a research fellow in
the program that could assist you
and uh I think that was it that I wanted
to share two different
um resources that you can leverage
throughout the research fellowship
program and also the specialization
tracks that you can work on
after your training is completed so that
was all if you have any question please
put it in the chat box so that I can
answer it for you
thank you so much sonalika so does the
participants have any queries
uh please put them in the chat box if
you're having any queries regarding the
specialization tracks or any of the
resources that was explained now
if not I'd like to invite sparse to talk
about the registration cost and how one
can enroll for the research fellowship
program so over to you expression
thank you so much
as well as SRI gauri
so let me share my screen and I'll
quickly explain how one can register and
what are the resources one would have
access to when they enroll in this
particular program
okay
so could you please confirm shree gauri
if my screen is visible
yes we can see the research fellowship
program page perfect
so uh this is the research Fellowship
landing page and I'll quickly share the
link here in the chat box thank you so
much or just be for sharing the link
so any like any participant who is
interested uh can scroll with me on this
particular page
so um This research fellowship program
is designed for everyone so there is no
constraint that a particular student of
a particular level of Education can only
enroll in this particular program we
have participants across Globe who are
either in their undergrad grad or maybe
in their post-graduation or also there
are faculties and researchers who have
been enrolled in this particular program
and they are like researching on
different domains on different area of
analysis
so this program is for all those young
researchers and students who want to
take advantage of bioinformatics
computational biology resources and want
to analyze complex Life Sciences data
and become well-versed in bioinformatics
and multi-amic field right so in this
particular program we will be providing
you with some good resources so the
First Resource as a resource is or mix
logic learn portal which SRI Guri have
already discussed in the beginning of
the presentation or the session I would
rather say so in this particular uh
or mix logic learn portal and the name
is self-explanatory so there are n
number of multiple or n number of
courseworks lessons example research
projects or case studies on different
domains on different area of analysis
which one can go through and Leverage
then you will have training then you
will have mentorship then you will have
access to the T bioinfo server with
sonalika just showed and then different
area of analysis which we have on our
platform through which you can learn
through which you can analyze and
through which you can interpret further
both statistically and biologically
so um in this research fellowship
program are we like uh in a very Layman
language I would say we have divided
This research fellowship program in
three stages so the first stage is to
get you trained the second stage is the
analysis part the literature review part
or the data set or methodology
finalization part and the third thing is
uh third stage is to jot it down
whatever you have done in your analysis
part right the first part that is the
training part
um
could you please see if if someone's mic
is on
okay
so yeah so I was saying the first stage
is the training part where one would go
through uh with different uh courses
different example research projects or
case study according to their research
area according to their research
interests and their research question
so
this particular stage we'll be doing
this we are the help of omix logic loan
portal once your training is done you
will jump on to the second state that is
your analysis stage and Analysis stage
includes literature review after
reviewing later literature you will be
finalizing a particular research
question on which you'll be working then
a particular data set on which you'll be
working and analyzing further and
prepare a particular methodology and
following that methodology you will come
up with the results and do the
biological and the statistical
interpretation further in the end so
this whole process is either either done
on the T by info server through running
pipelines on different area of analysis
or through the uh like coding part like
r or python or where we can include
machine learning or data science data
science aspect into it and then once it
is done you will be shifted over to the
third state that is the report writing
stage so whatever you have done in the
second stage your analysis stage you'll
be jotting down in a proper scientific
manner a proper scientific manuscript
and then
further publish it okay so
um
as you can see so these are the topics
which we'll be covering in the training
part that is Introduction to
bioinformatics and the basics of data in
life sciences so some if someone is
beginner in bioinformatics so there is a
particular course of that is
Introduction to bioinformatics through
which we'll be uh in like through which
we'll be helping them and guiding them
to know what exactly is bioinformatics
the terminologies in bioinformatics
different applications of bioinformatics
in healthcare in translational research
Etc and how bioinformatics and
computational biology tools can help in
cutting-edge research now uh the omics
data types like genomics transcriptomic
metagenomics or epigenomics then their
data science and machine learning
aspects for non-engineers and biologists
then R and Python Programming is there
now when we move on to Second Stage that
is the literature review and plan out
your project as I discussed briefly so
there are few steps there are few things
which you need to remember one is make a
research question compelling to those
already in the field
second set specific parameters to answer
the research question conclusively third
find data sets that fit your objectives
and explore them for batch effects or
bias and fourth get feedback from our
expert mentors on your topic and
Analysis proposal so these are few
things which you need to keep in mind
when you perform literature review and
plan out your whole analysis part your
whole methodology and the uh and next
what are the potential outcome so now
you have completed your project now your
research work is done so what are the
potential outcomes of This research
fellowship program so number one is
expert feedback and overall evaluation
of project quality Innovation and
Analysis execution the second is poster
presentation at the research fellowship
meeting or a research symposium
for a third is path to collaboration
with expert mentors or faculty at
partner University and fourth is path to
a full publication so these are some
potential outcomes of This research
fellowship program which one can have
you know Leverage
true now uh there are
three different tenures rather I would
say four different tenures in this
research fellowship program one is of 45
days another is 60 days then is three
months and then is six months so what is
the difference between uh these all
tenures there is no difference
particular uh to be very precise there
is no difference it's just 10 like the
analysis part so in 45 days and 60 days
there will be a kind of an intermediate
level of analysis you'll be maybe uh
like doing only the literature review
part and preparing a project kind of
report so whatever you have done in the
literature review thing that's all and
very minor reviewing would be their very
minor analysis would be there when it
comes to a full-fledged research project
so one should either choose the three
months or the six months so in the three
months or the six months we'll be
following the pattern I uh that I just
explained the stage one stage two and
stage three so the resources which one
would have access to are the
asynchronous courses the Hands-On
assignments group sessions program
course access omics logic program access
then educational Cloud pipelines or that
the table info server platform online
Mentor Support Online technical support
access to life group uh sessions
Etc
so these are the resources of all the
four tenures and the outcomes are for 45
days it's a literature review and a
project report then for 60 days it's
literature review project report and a
research poster for 60 for 90 days and
then for six months it's literature
review project report and a research
publication
okay now if someone is very much
interested so in in this particular page
only we have provided with the payment
links for all four tenures and right now
we are providing everyone with a 20
person scholarship and the coupon code
for that 20 scholarship is take 20. and
I have pasted the coupon code in the
chat box if anyone is interested they
can simply visit this page and click on
which particular tenure they want to
enroll for and if they want to complete
a research full flash project and come
up with a research publication or if
it's a like kind of a literature review
and prepare a project report only
according to your wish you can click on
this payment link
it will be redirected to the purchase
part you can fill out your credentials
of your card and then write the coupon
code and then pay now so uh so this is
this is how simple you can you know do
the payment part
if further I'll scroll down you can see
there are different students projects on
different domains like infectious
diseases space omics Precision oncology
machine learning skin disease data
driven drug Discovery Etc and as I go
down you can see our different
collaborators from all across the globe
and and the students from all these
collaborators have been a part of
research fellowship program or like they
are writer also doing their research
fellowship program with us
so this was a brief description and also
the mentors of this program so we have
industry and academic mentors and uh
they'll be guiding you according to the
expertise of their so we have a separate
Mentor for chem informatics and Drug
Discovery then a separate Mentor for
metagenomics or genomics part and a
separate for our python or data science
or machine learning thing so this is how
everything goes and these are some blog
posts about the student research
projects
so this was all about the registration
the resources and the payment how one
can do and also the scholarship so if
anyone is having any query regarding the
registration part or the scholarship
part or how one can Avail please feel
free to Ping in the chat box and I'll be
there to guide you how one can proceed
with the payment checkout process or any
anyway any kind of query so thank you
open to you SRI gauri
thank you so much so in the chat box I'm
pasting sparish's uh contact number and
her email ID that you can reach out the
contact number is also available on
WhatsApp so you could text her as well
so with that does the participants have
any queries about registration or their
specialization tracks that were
discussed if so uh you could either try
to unmute yourself and talk or you could
also share your queries in the chat box
[Music]
I'll pause for a few minutes
and if not
I will be ending the meeting soon
um I guess uh SRI gauri there are no two
questions
yeah if someone is having any kind of
question regarding the scholarship or
the registration part please feel free
to bring uh okay so Rekha is asked
something ma'am what is the registration
fee uh so Rekha could you please confirm
if you are from government City College
Hyderabad if I'm not wrong
there's nothing
perfect so uh Reka could you please DM
me your contact details uh so that our
one like one of our intern would uh
contact you and guide you about the
registration fee because we have a
specific uh discount or we can say a
specific scholarship for the partnership
uh like the partner or the collaborators
and government City College is one of
our collaborators yes thank you for the
email address yeah that's more better so
I've noted down your email address and
one of our intern would definitely uh
call or ping you
shortly
thank you so much Rekha there's any
other participants have any further
queries related to scholarship or
discount
if so please put them in the chat and
we'll be happy to help otherwise
uh thank you so much everyone for
today's participation and have a great
day thank you
[Music]